et bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale télé
spéciale championnat du monde adam
topalov très très grand match toujours
suivi sur votre tv puis aujourd'hui on
va recevoir pour la première fois sur
des gones ltv un maître international
marocain karim ismaël mon jour karim
bons joueurs alors tu es le passage à
paris passage pour quelques jours en
fait alors donc on va discuter pour
l'émission tu as trois cordes à son arc
oui parce que tu en fait tu vis
maintenant en espagne à malaga ou donc
là tu en activité pour le club de malaga
voilà donc je suis entraîneur à malaga
je joue aussi quelques tournois en
espagne sur le circuit espagnol donc un
circuit catalan dalo et je suis aussi
donc un peu organisateurs parce que là
on va organiser un très grand tournoi
marrakech alors ça c'est sa deuxième
carte c'est que tu continues évidemment
être actif au maroc qui organise un
grand tour de marrakech
quand tu m'as dit 4000 euros de prix je
crois qu'on promet aux 4000 euros promis
aux premiers chronos un peu plus de
quinze mille 15 mille euros de prix aura
judit polgar qui va venir à la fin du
tournoi pour donner une grande
simultanée à ça va attirer du monde ça
ça c'est important comme ça va très bien
je suis dans ce pôle gare on va rappeler
quand même à nos auditeurs c'est quand
même la plus grande joueuse de tous les
temps de tous les temps de tous les
temps qui est rentré dans le top 10
mondial masculin tout à fait en 2003 je
crois donc très grande joueuse donc ça
va être un tournoi intéressant et donc
s'ils les joueurs qui regarde sa
raquette je crois que là
allez jouer un tournoi marrakech mon
avis il ya forcément il ya forcément de
la demande et comme on trouve d'ailleurs
il ya un site internet un site internet
donc ses réussites delà de la société
donc du sponsor c'est www.thomson.net
faire donc olson voilà qu'olson point fr
donc tournés chaque séquence il est daté
du 26 juin au 1er juillet d'accord donc
c'est bientôt et de quoi nous qu'on
allait prendre le soleil voire des
grands maîtres en aura 20 jamais une
vingtaine peut être un peu plus et
beaucoup de joueurs à 2600 voilà d'être
très fort joueur donc du plaisir et puis
et puis une grande joueuse qui va venir
aussi alimenter tout ça ça va être très
très sympa donc à noter dans les
calendriers alors tu as une troisième
carte troisième corde à son arc ou une
troisième carte dans son jeu c'est qu'on
veut c'est que tu joues aussi en france
tu joues pour le club de grasse dans le
sud ne se pense pas loin de cannes et
antibes donc on joue en nationale 1
voilà donc tranquille cette année on a
terminé troisième du groupe l'objectif
c'est peut-être c'est terminé premier
pour pouvoir jouer le tome 2 la saison
moyenne qu'on va finalement on a terminé
troisième sahil bank une banque une
place où c'est les premiers simplement
où c'est le premier assez peu de revenus
rome l'an prochain l'an prochain on va
rappeler quand même que tu ai gratté m
depuis peu puisque tu as 24 ans et tu as
eu ton titre en 2008
donc tu es encore tout frais émoulu de
ce titre est-ce que tu vises le type de
grand est sans doute type de grand
maître
mais bon ça demande quand même pas
beaucoup des formes bien sûr dont il
faut jouer beaucoup de tournois faut
vraiment se concentrer enfin peut
s'isoler quand on veut devenir un grand
maître info travaille énormément donc
oui travail fondamental aussi bien sur
la psychologie jouer des tournois donc
bon peut-être peut-être l'année
prochaine on va voir on va voir oui bon
c'est vrai que c'est une étape déjà
d'être maître c'est quand même c'est
déjà une belle performance et après
après creuser le truc donc tu viens
commentaires venus au grand match au
pour les 11e et 12e partie tu viendras
aussi pour la 12è et alors est ce que
sur ce match que tu as suivi évidemment
tu vas un favori mon favori c'est un an
d'un bain c'est un joueur qui sait pas
ce qui ressemble à hicham c'est qu'il
ressemble à hesham d'ailleurs une
anecdote quand on était aux olympiades
en 2004 quand on a joué donc tout le
monde demander des autographes à richard
houis sharon douchy chamiers les
autographes à la place de la norme
le joueur pensait que c'était un endroit
ils voulaient pas leur dire que
montpellier quand même que hicham
hamdouchi et corps est aussi un très
très bon joueur puisqu'il est grand
maître international à il a fait partie
du top 100 et il peut s'il est encore
mais si con à 2600 mhz et 6 ans mon
client voilà d'où les temps plusieurs
fois champion d'afrique
finaliste du grand prix de bordeaux face
à anatoly karpov
alors ça ça date de 2005 très grande
rencontre qui s'est terminée froid à la
mort subite qui s'est terminée en mort
subite exactement match énorme match et
n'ont donc
donc ton new fabris et à nos voisins
parce que je pense que c'est un joueur
plus complet qui a quand même montré de
très grandes performances notamment lors
de son dernier match face à cramique
quand même oui sur deux points de
différence de partie avec les noirs ils
commencent à avoir d'expérience en match
dont il a joué déjà steam mac depuis
très longtemps je pense 195 déjà new
york
oui face à casillas membres et sur la
casse par off dans les tours les
anciennes tordu c'est au rythme du world
trade center bien sûr et donc il a joué
2 il a joué contre karpov aussi des mois
une finale de championnat du monde quand
c'est quelqu'un qui a énormément
d'expérience en match en tournoi c'est
un joueur très complet
je pense qu'il est un peu plus favori
que oui assez universel et puis qu'est
un teint naturel puisque à ses débuts il
jouait extrêmement vite des coûts
extrêmement compliqué à voir il avait
l'habitude alors de prendre 20 minutes
pour ces partis alors qu'il y avait il
avait trois heures il faut les bons bref
il était extrêmement rapide et lucide
alors b on y va pour cette deuxième
partie alors en ce moment du match
anand et topalov sont à égalité donc le
match devient tendue puisque il reste
plus que deux parties en cas d'égalité
au bout de ces deux partis il y aurait
des partages mais toutes parties gagnées
à ce moment là du match bas et sans
doute décisive
bien sûr donc on y va un an dall et
blanc pas facile et première surprise
dès le premier coup on va dire puisque
pour la première fois du match
raf alors c'est le coup du fou c'est pas
le coup de la dame c'est le coup du pion
du fou ici le coup c4 alors d'habitude
tous les autres partis du match que ce
soit d'ailleurs un ado topalov ils ont
tous joué le pion de la dame de d2 d4
donc là il petites variations on peut
dire presque envie de dire à la fischer
c'est à dire que le coc inattendu un
écho inattendu mais fisher avait joué
une fois ces quatre pour surprendre son
adversaire
ouais ça se passe rien 72 alors qu'il ne
jouait jamais même lui-même un tournoi
new par coin c'était bon bref c'était
voilà la grande surprise alors donc la
c4 donc comme une demi surprise parce
que c'est pas non plus un coût qui
change forcément tous les schémas on
peut retrouver des ouvertures habituel
est alors ici topalov
ou 1,5 alors ce qui est intéressant
qu'on va quand même noté avant de
commenter la suite et on va revenir
juste sur ce coup sec
topalov aurait pu tenter de jouer le
coup de 6 avec l'idée de revenir dans
une mine sous vide darcis du blanc avait
joué t4 après derrière cavaliers m6 par
exemple qu'il a blessé trois on aurait
vu une lime zoo comme ça qu'il avait
déjà joué dans le match qu'il avait déjà
joué dans en fait dans le match ils ont
joué des catalanes en fait dans le match
je pense que
oui ou non et à jouer tout le temps
cavaliers f3 voilà il ajoute toujours et
tout un collectif
trois des cinq avec g3 fou j'ai deux
noms là en fait en fait après ces quatre
donc six cavaliers c3 alors après
cavalli c3 ici apprennent maintenant
cavalli et 6 les blancs la possibilité
de jouer aux quatre de l'occasion en
empêcher il n'y a pas ce coup là n'est
pas grave puisque le câliner n'est pas
clouer en fait sur le roi de protéger
donc après fou bk ton jour est tout
simplement donc au 4-5-1 joué que cinq
attaques
lecavalier 6 et sur un coup comme franck
laval y est
si on prend alors ce pion de la dame
puisque on ouvre le jeu pour la dame et
six cavaliers 1,4 ce serait une grosse
erreur voilà dame g4 puisque dame chez
quatre attaques à la fois le cavalier ou
4 et sa viande les 7 avec un massacre
quelques gardes quelques coups il ya
plus de défense de ce côté là et c c'est
le massacre je suis pris un peu le pied
dans les films alors donc
donc voilà l'idée de la subtilité de ce
coup sûr qu'on peut pas vraiment ses
formes en ciel et blanc peuvent choisir
de ne pas jouer les variantes
habituellement ne varietur par exemple
même que par exemple
topalov aussi des fois pas joué ces six
oui bien sûr qu'ils étaient malades
voilà et ici on peut répondre par quatre
en fait et en rendant une carte cannes
en faire une car au cas d'une attaque
panov après deux des cinq dessins qu'on
peut prendre part le pion et je voulais
des cadres des choses comme ça donc des
structures complètement différentes qui
peuvent un peu embêté topalov donc ces
quatre ou cinq et simplement donc ici
donc la taupe alors donc du coup accepte
qu'on va direct puisque saint cloud coup
classique ou de l'anglais en fait on est
dans une anglaise le classique
ils répondront ils répondent répond
généralement par par 5 contre ces quatre
et pas avec des très bons résultats je
crois qu'il a eu de petits problèmes
justement face à kremnica d'autres
joueurs donc ça va être peut-être que
hollande avait aussi c'était peut-être
une arme d'un an
normes d'amandes en fin de match pour
déstabiliser stabilise faire peur c'est
aussi la psychologie qui joue à nancy le
joueur mauvais résultat sur cette
ouverture
même si elle n'a pas l'habitude de la
jouer il peut tenter la jouer pour
essayer de le faire de lui faire perdre
qui donc a laissé 3 km 6 alors recensé
logique les plats en sortent leurs
cavaliers menwar aussi cavalière 3 donc
là pour l'instant c'est normal car elle
nécessite aussi voyager alors ça c'est
très classique c'est ce qu'on dit aux
débutants ou sortez vos cavaliers dans
les faux et puis après les fous donc là
pour l'instant on est on est vraiment
dans le classique et la g3 donc
finalement atteint de rebasculer dans un
schéma avec g3 donc c'est ce qu'ils
avaient tous jouer dans le match aussi
crucial et donc j'ai trois projets de
avec petit rock et ensuite on un petit
rock ensuite et puis après on joue au
centre des 4 ou 4 2 3 des 4 derrière
enfin tout un tas d'idées possible hélas
alors là beaucoup quand même responsable
puisque d525 là on joue presque une
c'est presque une sicile est à l'envers
une dragonne inverse les recalés en
général plutôt les blocs entre cette
structure et quand les noirs je vous ça
mais là les blancs c'est comme si je
jouais avec les noirs bravo mais avec un
temps de plus dur étant de plus en
sachant qu'on ne choisit en général d'un
bon petit avantage mais ça permet aussi
aux noirs de pouvoir observer son
adversaire et donc de choisir le bon
plan c'est pour ça qu'en général donc
les ouvertures avec un temps de plus ne
donne pas forcément l'avantagé sur
donkey six epr en dessert non non on est
en échange un pion du centre un contre
un pion de leyme donc ça ça soulage le
centre qui ont menacé d'être
on ouvre aussi une colonne ceni ouverte
la colonne s'est on va servir pour la
tour calais prenait 5 fu jeu tranquille
il a donc attention que la ici tu crois
tu m'as fait signalé on a vu un peu à
partir en turc à malvési c'est important
parce que là si tu si les noirs jouer
foule 6 direct des deux des quatre ans
je jouais des cadres et avec avec une
pression on peut jouer je crois que
c'est au lieu de jouer des deux des
quatre la variante c'est en fait petit
rock d'abord voilà fawcett est
maintenant des deux des quêtes talons
des 80 le plus précis et la maintenance
cette variante normalement donne donne
un petit avantage aux blancs donc après
pions prendre des quatre en général
cavaliers prend des quatre n'a ouvert
donc la grande diagonale donc h 1 à 8
pour le fou qui exerce une très forte
pression sur toutes les diagonales sur
le canal et ses six notamment donc c'est
un jeu qui va favoriser les blancs grâce
à se [ __ ] est très bien placé mais les
normands pas intérêt évident comme celle
qui joue un second temps ouvrir le jeu
trop vite il faut il faut qu'ils
consolident leur position n'a pas donc
ici ou g2 donc calais b si c'est là
l'idée c'est que bombay simplement on
contrôle la casse des cas pour contrôler
cette case ici donc on empêche
l'ouverture du jeu prématurée
deux des cas pour les noirs par contre
ça serait ça serait bon pour les mains
donc petit rock et là vous êtes
tranquillement on se pourrait qu'on se
dépêche de roquet avant d'engager
d'action ici alors petit coup 30 il a
trois alors on s'attend pas à ce genre
de combine dans cette position parce que
si on faisait on se dit bon ben il ya
encore le fossé qu'il faut développer
alors on peut imaginer comme détroit
puisqu'on peut pas jouer des 4 et puis
on va essayer de sortir se fout pas
d'emploi de trois ou un des deux elle en
fait ici une des grandes idées c'est que
il faut c'est comme dans la sicilienne
donc en fait il faut attaquer al elle
dame donc soit attaqué de ce côté en
général dans la neige d'or fonds joue à
6 suivi de bessens qu'ici ça va être à 3
suivi de b4 pour déstabiliser le pion
aux cinq ans fait avec décathlon va
menacer des 5 alors on va menacer le
bessin pour déstabiliser ce cavalier qui
protège 5 voilà donc en fait c'est une
attaque indirecte du piaui c5 et or s'il
répondait par un coup comme assène un
coup grande richesse a empêché 4 mais en
fait ici on donne la case aussi b5 ce
qui peut être peut-être une opportunité
peut-être que je vais déjà cavaliers
cavaliers b4 suivi kama db5 suivi de d2
d4 avec un temps voilà dans ce cas là on
pourrait ça pourrait permettre cavaliers
ici on protège une nouvelle fois la
casse des quatre avec lecavalier et ça
peut envisager plus de 6 pi 4 avec un
qu'est-ce bessac affaibli et une colonne
c'est qui va être intéressante
après aussi avec un cavalier bien placé
une tour et on peut faire pression pour
envisager aussi pourquoi pas deux mais
trois simplement de rappel ce tour c'est
un et puis on veut montrer la praticité
donc ces problèmes de ce genre de coup
même en jouant à celle qu'on affaiblit
des cases de son côté il ya toujours un
désavantage approuvé les virulents faut
faire très attention à cette voie
n'hésites toujours entre les bulls et
les papous violait pas les bouger
et puis ça dépend à 90 qu'est ce que
c'est compliqué alors petit rock
tranquillement et moi simplement fond le
rock il faut le fait bien le faire ton
ta et le plus vite possible c'est le
mieux et à des cas voilà donc c'est
l'idée d'une menace des blancs tout de
suite
pouf attaque le cavalier et sur cet ep
culture donc il faut réagir
et bizarrement les noirs ne font rien
puisque fin il ne faut rien contre cette
menace directe en tout cas puisqu'ils
jouent fou aussi donc ça c'est un coup
tactique donc l'idée en fait c'est
qu'après b 4 des 5 alors à prélever 5
il y aura cavaliers c6 des cats et après
cavalier est sain qui vit en d4 et après
45 ans gagne donc on a mangé un pont le
problème c'est qu'on perd la dame après
four b3 foulée trois perfs à la dame de
ski adam 20 mais bon il y aura cavaliers
cde et la perte de la tour en 1 la dame
est attaqué par le fou la dame n'a plus
qu'une case en eux et là pouf la fameuse
la fameuse fourchette en plus la dame de
revenir en d'élan n'attaquera deux
nouveaux l'adage on tournait en fait on
est donc il faut pas qu'il faut faire
très attention hein pas être gourmande
échec aussi attention puisque là on le
voit sur
donc sur cette variante il faut faire
attention aux pièges donc les blancs
jouent non pas directement ces bandes
mais détroit et là par contre ils
menacent de faire l'opération puisque la
dame a une case en moins des docks
l'opération aube et 5 devient une vérité
telle est la thèse que coup suivant des
noirs f6 sexisme aurait pu tenter
peut-être à 6 aussi pour empêcher bessin
mais si c'est pas mal on protège aussi
fortement le pion le sien voyons ne se
presse pas on consolide et puis ça
permet de d'avoir un oeil sur la caisse
des cadres qu'on essaiera de consolider
peut-être plus tard donc là les blancs
poursuivent leur développement avec le
coup suivant qu'on va expliquer qui est
cavalier e 4 alors ça c'est intéressant
puisqu'on joue une pièce qui a déjà joué
il ya plus que le footsie a bougé alors
l'idée de cavaliers ou 4
c'est notamment mais la casse ces scènes
dont on voit qu'elle est protégée par le
pion et on voit que b ce cavalier va
attaquer par la fois le pion bessette
qui est pas protégé le fou au cices
si ça permet de forcer des coups comme
fou s'est vite c'est bien on aura gagné
du temps c'est un avant poste donc en
fait un avant poste
donc c'est une case donc sur la
cinquième rang j'ai sur une colonne
s'est mis au vert tu vois là parce qu'on
peut aussi on pourrait imaginer aussi
n'est sûr jouer d'abord le four b2 par
exemple puis tour c1 et cabanès elle son
cas et ses 5 après la ce qui permettrait
à voir en plus donc reprendre de la tour
s'il était prix égal voire une pression
sur le côlon 6 alors là les noirs jouent
le coup ici d'un de 8
donc ils laissent faire en fait pour
l'instant le plan des blancs par d'un 8
alors pourquoi c'est un coup mystérieuse
tellement vite je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs idées on peut vouloir venir en
aide à être pour faire flamber 3d fois
peut-être des fois jouent et damages 5
on peut aussi jouer dommage c'est pour
faire flasher trois échanges et les fous
de cases blanches voilà il changer ce
fou quand on a vu qu'il était puissant
alors il ya du matériel aller chercher
là puis à la classe des cinq ou six qui
est contrôlé aussi à travers un lancer
eux c'est pas parce qu'il ya deux
cavaliers que ça contrôle pas parce que
ces qualifs peuvent bouger à tout le
monde donc cette dame là là elle
retrouve des bonnes cases et finalement
qu'il libère aussi de la place pour la
tour à 8 m en fait c'est un coup assez
sombre parce que bon qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait jouer à la place de damas huit
parce que si on met la dame en 17 par
exemple là il va falloir bouger la dame
pour pouvoir corde reliée détour dans le
son jeu dans 17 en fait ça donne tout
simplement un temps un temps au blanc
après qu'elle va laisser saint cloud
prend ses cinq ou dix terrains peut même
ne pas se presser aux jouets poupées de
tours ca et quand on jouera qu'à laisser
5 on l'attaquera en tout cela d'un alors
voilà donc bien sûr donc ça donnerait du
du feu à la tapenade verte est un donc
dans ma vie se justifie par toutes ces
raisons avec aussi des bonnes cases on
voit bien on a libéré lacazette s'est
donc c'est bien ça permettrait d'avoir
une petite batterie et un bon contrôle
de cette diagonale qui peut être utile
dante les blancs des fonds tout de suite
maintenant car ssl donc ça sur le choix
intéressant on aurait pu faire autre
chose mais ça c'est le choix d'un an il
a pas que tout de suite le fou le pion à
l'origine d'un coup comme pouces et 8
est envisageable pour parer les deux
menaces et a comme savait le fou protège
de pions le fou n'est plus attaquées ni
le pion mais alors du coup on enferme la
tour et puis on a perdu du temps avec ce
faux bond à la sortie on l'a remis en
attendant les plantes développent donc
on ne peut pas tellement justifier ce
genre de coups donc en fait qu'un essai
5 c'est un très bon coup son idée c'est
donc qu'ils occupent l'avant pas sur la
case 16,5 et après fou qu'ont ces 5
il y aura donc des princes et 5 avec
l'ouverture de la colonne b alors un
plus on a ouvert cette colonne qui va
pouvoir attaquer le pion de behcet avec
en plus une pioncer qui empêche ses
pions trop de bouger donc et en plus on
appris apa de la paire de fond donc la
fameuse paire de fou bon ok pas décisif
mais qui est souvent quand même un
avantage en finale notamment si le jeu
est relativement nouvelles règles pour
l'instant bay hill et c'est une position
qui peut s'ouvrir assez violemment
si si les noms ne font pas ne font pas
grave alors dépenser cercle cas les
décès est évidemment on évite la prise
et on centralise le cavalier c'est quand
même un bon coup facile à avoir un très
beau cavalier qui est bien central qui
peut venir en c3 pour l'instant en plus
donc c'est un péché tout de suite par
food et tranquillement leur four b2 donc
là se fout bombay idées développées pour
l'instant il tape contre une muraille
ici bon donc il a une action qui est
quand même limité par l'instant par la
structure d'appui ont en fait il ya
quelque chose qui est très important
dans ce dans ce type de configuration
donc ici les blancs d'oeuf ou un
cavalier contre donc de cavaliers et un
fou le cavalier est un fou donc ici
c'était ce qui est très important c'est
ce qu'on appelle en fait le jeu de
couleurs donc en fait les blancs vont
devoir jouer sur les cases noires vu que
les noirs n'ont pas de faute cases
noires oui donc voilà il est le fou de
cases noires alors le fou noir et son
casque blanc blanche voilà donc qui a il
manque encore ccc ce cas qui nous
intéresse donc nous on va essayer de
jouer tous les deux des quatre et de
jouer sur les cas ce moment veut jouer
des 4es explosé
sandy casar a pris souffrent cusson remy
qui est derrière la vie si on arrive
exploser ses pions honoraires fou d'
attaques contre le roi noir qui vous
s'avérait décisif et donc les blancs
vont essayer de jouer sur les cases
blanches donc leur voile a contrario
contrario parce qu'ils ont la foudre
cases blanches ski anti naturel parce
qu'en général au départ la dame blanche
il tend sur caisse blanche
on joue plutôt selon les cas cela avec
un oeil vers c'est leur amour des cases
donc ça c'est très important
stratégiquement donc c'est pas assez
mais ce n'est pas valable que dans cette
position mais dans tous les types de
position quand on a deux fous et un
cavalier il faut toujours jouer sur les
cases dont le l'adversaire n'a pas de
nom pas de fous moi là c'est la règle
c'est la règle d' essayer de viser en
général me même
oui c'est toujours quand on a les deux
fous de jouer là où le fouette personnes
cariocas dire que c'est là où la
différence post fait enfin donc alors
tourner vite pour les noirs donc sa
consolidation la décentralisation
centralisation pas deux des quatre
appels à la maison pour l'instant à
noter aussi des petites menaces comme
deux cas peuvent maintenant commencer à
être à apparaître parce que si les
blancs prennent un 24e suffit de sortir
ce travail par exemple en droit et la
tour attaquerez la dame donc cela il
faudrait parler donc ça peut être
embêtant donc ça explique le coup
suivant l'homme ccdh on enlève la ddt a
finalement dû vis-à-vis de la tour
évidemment et un coup comme dame b 3-1
aux réalités ont vis-à-vis du fou cette
fois donc il y aurait lieu cavaliers et
3 près d'am b3 avec donc une belle
attaque voilà sur dingue b3 aussi il y
aurait eu quand même cavalier ou 3 il ya
le fou attaque la dame
il faut bouger et après bon on prend la
qualité la qualité une autre allocution
peut être envisageable damas quatre
aussi le recueil être envisagée là du
coup là ya pas trop la menace combine
cité il ya attention il ya même des
menaces
la famille
classique devrait quand même cette
menace puisque regarder sur calais des
cats et la dame 1,8 qui attaque et si
les blancs échange on ad'abord
l'intermédiaire classique car les prends
les deux échecs et gérer la cécilienne
dragon exact de même piège quand dans la
drague on a pris trois ans on reprend et
gagne un pion tout simplement la preview
2 mai donc on a un pion de plus une
meilleure structure de pioncer un net
avantage pour les noirs les plus simples
aux centrales
donc en fait ya pas vraiment de choix
sur tours de 8 il faut faire quelque
chose n'est pas à cause du visa me avec
4 qui menacent donc c'est presque ce
coup là mais elle donne 1000 bon ouais
surtout il est correct ici je pense que
si peut-être qu'il ya une idée peut-être
qui est de jouer d3 d4 et ou de
contrôler la case de 4 il ya aussi bien
sûr il ya aussi alors il est bon et en
plus on contrôle la casaque l'a donc si
des cats pour essayer d'exploser cette
structure avec l'aide du fou avec l'aide
du cavalier eh bien elle est noire ne
pourrait pas jouer le 4 pour éviter les
changes puisque la dame talent contrôler
cette case très importants dont
cavaliers ou cette voie là et la belle
idée des noirs c'est que là bas on
contrôle des quatre par la tour donc
cavalier touré pions 3 contre simplement
deux défenseurs et donc ça tient pas on
peut pas jouer des quatre voilà très
simplement
donc tous les coups s'explique et là
alors c'est ce que tu dit tout à l'heure
après tout à b1 et b2 impressionnant sur
le pion bessette
batum au mans 2 peut-être joué ou c3 et
puis le pion v7 est attaqué et on a des
problèmes on a peut-être aussi ébauché
le cavalier lecavalier qui en f3
peut-être le cavalier des deux pour
essayer de aussi peut-être qu'à valider
de aussi madiran ses cadres et puis
peut-être plus tard à faire des
pressions sur cette structure depuis
propos bicloo
après il continuerait de jouer donc il
commence à y avoir des idées alors le
coup suite aux plaintes du coup
s'explique très très mal elle petit coup
qu'il faut savoir jouer parce que on
joue fois de me dire oui mais alors faut
2 mais si on joue torah ils doivent s'en
aller oui mais dans ce cas là les blancs
ils sont obligés de jouer autre chose
que tomber le salon il répète l'équipe
voilà donc c'est un coût qui dit ben si
tu fais ça je tends pêche et je reviens
aux 6 après si tu reviens et je répète
les coûts sont pas très bien la bulle
gilet noir et c'est vrai que on est
proche de la fin du match j'ai pas envie
de prendre trop de risques avec les
noirs forcément demain j'aurai des
blanches pour la mettre un peu plus de
pression donc là dans ce genre de
position il faut justifier en quelque
sorte faut essayer de rendre ce coup
presque inefficace et donc ça se fait
partout bce sert quand je joue la tour
sur un endroit actifs
simplement on si on l'avait joué tout de
suite le fou noir série n 6 et donc les
noirs auraient le trait voilà hélas le
foulard comme ça car il y avait une
petite mousse blanche quand même qui
peut qui doit falloir calculer c'est fou
prendre pions recettes et la dame
attaque le faux faux pas de avec en plus
un petit échec au passage pas peur donc
il faut quand même par et ça alors c'est
s'explique ou suivante au pôle très
logique
voyez des combats les menaces les coûts
sont logiques darif cette voie là la
dame protège le fouet et c'est un peu
aussi c'est un peu ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure donc c'est le jeu sur les
cases blanches on voit bien que les que
les noirs jour sur les cases blanches le
fond en a deux la dame en effet cette
lecavalier ans et 6 on contrôle bien le
centre et on joue sur les cases blanches
alors que sur les cases noires mais pour
l'instant laisser les pions qui font
office de
un parent de rempart pour l'instant qui
tiennent bien et 6 et puis on arrive à
sauter qu'on a vu il y aurait quand même
beaucoup de trophées sobrement donc il
faut absolument que cette structure
tiennent pour l'instant ça tient à pas
de problème là donc
et puis en plus bon sur cette idée on va
retrouver l'idée four b3 qui va
désorganiser un peu les pièces blanches
donc poussé 3 2
danone donc intéressant sous ces trois
bombes et s'apprend comme des cases
parce que le careï à s'inquiéter
on pouvait aussi envisagé qu'à et
hasselt pour venir en b3 mon problème et
la torah ou mètres la tour
donc là on joue au foot est roi où là on
joue ces trois ici voilà on contrôle
cette case et on permet aussi à la dame
de venir en b2 pour attaquer le pion
bessette voilà en b2 en plus ce sera un
petit oeil là-dessus c'est alors qu'il
faut pas que la dame ne bouge donc ça
immobilise la dame en noir en offset et
sur dames les deux futurs monde nous
sommes attaqués visite mais là aussi on
aura une petite batterie dame fou pour
nous est et quatre qui est sûre
quasiment toujours les femmes donc là on
aura on pourra jouer des 4 4 donc c'est
un coup multifonctions ce que vous et 3
tout s'explique en fait c'est la
stratégie alors roy 17 pardon prend 17
tours 17 ans donc tout décède alors
l'idée pour les noirs c'est comme les
blancs veulent venir en d2 commencé à
faire des misères sur la place des
quatre est aussi attaqué 17 on veut sans
doute doubler les tours au centre pour
avoir un contrôle accru de la colonne
des de la caisse d empêcher les blancs
de jouer sur les quinze mois et
d'empêcher sur les quatre mois donc ici
d'un bep 2 attention quand même parce
qu'il a l'air de manquer d'un noir parce
qu'on pourra pas jouer ton des huit
puisque la tension d'un premier set
c'est pourquoi je dois rejoue finalement
tourné huit
c'est quand même étonnant alors tombé
huit au lieu de jouer un coup comme b6
messi serait pas très bon sens serait
pas très bon parce qu'on menace pas de
prendre parce qu'après on aurait des
pions doublé dont ils demandent la
structure de pions après qu'un qu'on
pourrait qu'on pourrait récupérer depuis
ces 5 ensuite par cavalier des deux
cavaliers aux quatre cavaliers français
cinq français 5 avec un très beau
cavalier ici bien placé et puis alors
aussi maintenant qu'on a joué des six
toute la colonne c'est faible parce
qu'il n'ya plus vraiment de cases
quand il a pris la présence et 5 à 6,5
du produit n'est pas protégé la ccist
ont pu casser cette non plus le cas ici
c'est instable puisqu'il est attaqué par
le projet 2 et en plus par la colonne
donc ça serait un très mauvais coup qui
désorganise or il est donc en fait
trouver 8 mai on n'hésite pas à protéger
le camp
après tout c'est bien une dalle qui
mobilise et attaques des pions on peut
très bien mobiliser une tour à la
défense mais le coût des quatre mais non
on n'est plus vraiment un peu plus
vraiment d'empêcher quoi sauf que quand
même si on peut on pourra jouer le katla
que la cible en juillet de 4 des cas
tout de suite on pourrait simplement je
vais envisager que quatre et on a
empêché l'ouverture de cette ligne
et une fois qu'on a joué ça on pourrait
protéger par yves celle qui ensuite ont
joué au foot et 5 et on verrouille
blocage sur les cases blanches et
locales avec un petit avantage
positionnelle pour pour les noirs donc
ça serait pas une bonne idée donc il
faut pas se presser pour jouer des cas
malgré tout des huit ici malgré que des
quatre soit possible à cause de quatre
faudrait d'abord arriver à bloquer cette
case 4 donc à ne se presse pas il joue
simplement tour eiffe d'ailleurs donc
ils préparent comme les limaces ces
pièces pour préparer son coup et
peut-être que il va se décider à jouer
eux 4 et des 4,6 joue de quatre blocs
alors une autre idée aussi c'est le cas
elles étaient deux pour pablo vue pour
pas bloquer son fou ici empêcher venir
lui avec le charisme vocal pour empêcher
ou 4 et ensuite des cadres il ya aussi
aussi à un an des sans doute un des plus
grands joueurs positionnelle de
l'histoire des échecs et donc il a des
plans qui sont vraiment très très
profond
je me rappelle aussi d'une de ces partis
en ses murs rapide en corse en 2003 une
très belle espagnole qui l'a gagnée face
à adams et donc il vous des coups qu'on
comprend pas forcément tout de suite
mais qui vont art dont on va comprendre
la stratégie beaucoup plus tard donc ici
en fait il a aussi une idée donc moi g
garder un petit peu la partie donc je
pense que en fait dans la partie il a
joué tour d2 et en fait son idée
stratégique c'est qu'il veut attaquer le
fou à deux attaques et se fait reprendre
le contrôle de la colonne b aiea prix
mettre une boucle peut-être doubler sur
la colonne b et exercer une pression sur
le pion 17 donc ça c'est vrai mandat
très très grande stratégie pour femise
d'attaqué au centre pour attaquer on les
fait silence sur les côtés il est malin
donc tous rêvent d l'un donc voilà
relation idéale or ici bas la compagnie
voit un peu peut-être cette idée aussi
arriver parce qu'il est mal aussi
ouais donc et je fous à 6 tout de suite
donc ici faut aussi voilà donc il enlève
cette idée tout de suite il n'y a pas de
menace mais par contre il lâche le
contrôle de
bien donc tournée de quand même parce
que si on joue trop bien évidemment on
pourra revenir 26 donc moi on compte
autour des 2 tranquillement il a
finalement de toppers vous presque au
coude attentes
hc ashes ses limites discute alors
l'intérêt quand il doit aussi c'est
qu'on comprend la case du 500 en pêche
des cas légers sexy on a dans l'idée de
jouer
f 5 e 4 ça peut être une idée plus tard
c'est une possibilité mais aussi bon
disons que c'est passé pas risquer dans
ce type de position parce qu'on a quand
même la dame en et pousse à être le fou
en aussi son contrôle assez bien les
cases blanches et on voit pas on voit
pas comment les blancs pour exploiter
cette faiblesse rapidement peut-être par
cas d'ali h4 suivi de fouet au 4 mai on
voit que les blancs n'ont pas d'accès
liés à la case f5 ni à la case j'assiste
des choses comme ça mais le cavalier
protège le fou aussi dans cette case est
tenu donc c'est là par contre on a peur
quand on bretons pas l'autre joué ça
parce que ici quand même pris une raclée
mémorable
à la cinquième je crois en affaiblissant
son roi il a pris 1 h il s'est pris un
gros sacrifice arrache hisse donc en
avance dit je vous trouve à chisseaux
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais bon dans
l'autre partie
il y avait quand même beaucoup de pièces
qu'ils pouvaient attaquer la wii alors
que la non la règle
on voit bien que le jeu quand même + mas
est ici d'avoir les pièces courtes sont
bien du côté dames ici du côté nord et
en plus ce fou il vise bien à donc c'est
pas tellement droit pour l'instant ça
peut venir plus tard mais pour l'instant
tout cas c'est pas le rang qui attaque
et donc ici simplement comme souvent la
nand intéressant donc donne des vins
tranquilles alors d'un meilleur accès à
des vidéos control4 donc contre leucate
donc on l'a maintenant on veut menacer
toujours des quatre et en menacent aussi
tombé deux et on menace alors en garde
un oeil sur 17
donc ça et vite tomber buts et en plus
on peut menacer tour b2 avec double à
domicile attaques fortes sur 17 donc de
menaces donc c'est un coup
multifonctions c'est un très très très
jolis plans d'un autour d un tour des
deux tombes tourbe et de très très
belles manoeuvres et l'a donc natu pa
leur réagi
puis sa main avec un coût de
recentralisation puisqu'il remet son
cavalier en des scènes cavalier e des 5
alors se faisant quand même l'ennui de
ce coup évidemment c'est que ça enlève
un contact de la casse des caps mais ça
attaque le fou donc là on peut alors
voilà c'était aussi évidemment on ouvre
les cases noires mais qu'on a éliminé le
foot classement alors je demanderai donc
là on se demande pourquoi non dans ce
cas là il a joué un an des jo is it au
bénin on fait ce qu'on va voir pourquoi
ils n'auraient pas un coup comme un coup
logique
enfin tout cas qu'à l'ère géologie comme
fou à 1 dans ses duels avec l'idée mais
je vais quand même je jouais des cadres
ça aussi c'est une possibilité mais je
pense donc que bon ici te pas la forêt
peut-être joué un coup comme comme
cavalier cette cavale ils sont revenus à
auxerre est revenu parce qu on n y
aurait pas eu leur lot d 4d 4 comme un
des quatre côtés est maintenant tourbe
est tombé dès 8 avec une pression sur la
colonne des alors maintenant autour des
8 et je lâche décède mais c'est pour
contre attaquer sur des cartes et les
blancs ne peuvent pas prendre une scène
puisqu'ils la tour d2 ces emprises c'est
ça le piège
et oui donc ça marche pas en fait c'est
bon c'est pas encore assez pas mûres
donc s'explique pour cette fois c'était
aussi une peu je pense une possibilité
c'était intéressant il ya vraiment
beaucoup de plans mais je pense que ici
à nantes je jouais sur les cases
blanches maintenant il se dit je vais
donner me [ __ ] cases noires et je vais
jouer sur les cases blanches avec la
dame en b1 la tour en b2 la dame et
socquettes blanches ici ont des russes
ont valu
on va attaquer bessette et 6e puis on
bouge c'est le foot chez nous qui se
réveille et qui commence à attaquer des
pièces et des cases et des cases
intéressant donc on y va tomber deux
donc voilà donc on a vu un autre plan et
qui on a vu qu'ils avaient aussi ses
inconvénients
donc la tombe est nommé leur évidemment
alors à b6 maintenant tranquillement
pour les noirs ne voyait pas de problème
puis ont pu maintenant le fou de couture
reculé alors si il s'enlève bon mais du
coup il sera plus actif sur cette
diagonale
ça va être difficile de le remettre au
centre on s'était peut-être possible de
jouer un chaos food et 2 on va donner le
foot cases noires vu qu'on peut jamais
prendre en c5 pour l'instant et puis en
même temps dont on exerce une pression
aussi sur la colonne s'est un peu menacé
maintenant ses preuves et 625 devant le
cab a nécessité un coût très intéressant
il faut des deux aussi je pense que
c'était une option intéressante
ça permettait aux puces on voit que
c'est une position qui est vraiment
toutes les pièces sont alors mises en
place la question sont activés on a
presque une attaque de minorité de ce
côté là avec qu'on a deux pions ici
contre trois avec une belle pression des
tours influents soutiens ma foi c'est
une position qui sont agréables m'en
fous des deux alors il n'a pas choisi
saanen il a choisi simplement de prendre
en b6 s'éprend b6 donc ses preuves et
six des morts alors évidemment ça c'est
bien joué de la part topalov regarder
puisqu'il enlève le pion c'est de la
colonne donc du coup il ya moins de
cible il ya une pression si les prix
depuis un an il y aurait toujours une
cible en cinq sets et puis en plus il
bombe et libère aussi ces pièces qui
peuvent maintenant circuler librement
sur la septième rangée donc ça peut être
utile aussi donc là ici maintenant sous
2 voilà c'est maintenant que je vis tu
me fous des deux alors attention parce
que on voit tout de suite l'action mais
non voilà c'est vrai alors c'est le
c'est l'idée du plan d'un an après cette
prise c'est que la torah taxes et 6 et
on va pouvoir doubler sur la collation
la colonne s'est donc on y va on active
tour des six protection de topalov alors
ça c'est intéressant parce qu'on laisse
la tour au centre permet peut-être à la
dame de venir à la rescousse société
saine permet d'accéder à la tour aussi
pourquoi pas
comment devenir ans et 8 aussi la
centralisation la centralisation de
doublage de tours donc la menace devient
effective contre le cavalier et la voilà
bien exactement autour du cou c'est
facile on protège ici tranquillement
voilà le cavaly cjce qu'on peut enlever
aussi une autre chose on est enfin là
ils centralisent parce qu'en même temps
au milieu augmente la pression s'ils
n'ont rien sur la colonne d'air ça peut
être utile
peut-être quatre un moment comme en
invitant à la rare d'être des idées à
base de leucate pour casser cette
structure et on notera taquet sur leur
volonté
donc là jusqu'à fort ça c'est un coup de
pouce de gains espace simplement gagner
un peu d'espacé ça veut dire que bon
mais il n'a pas de nous il n'ya pas de
suite force et donc ils gagnent elles
peu l'espace et les droits ça peut être
utile
ça peut être aussi une case de repli
pour un cavalier qui pourraient plus
tard pour l'instant c'est bien contrôler
mais ça peut être longue ou alors mettre
le roi aussi gagner du temps a empêché
ou sinon peut-être déjà 5,1 et hsu 5 qui
pourrait être un plan des noirs amusant
mais pourquoi pas jouer g5 g4 chasser le
cavalier f3 et rentrer ensuite sur la
case des cats avec lecavalier 6 essais
ira au centre mais sur cela il a chassé
ce cavalier f3 le câble et noir au
centre sera très forte accra la tour le
qe2 ça fera beaucoup donc tour des huit
ici des noirs après h théâtre donc qui
empêche un peu ce coup j'essaie alors
tour des 8es la dent bessaih menace bat
tours pareille date prises ici puisque
on a que deux défenseurs contre trois
attaquants n'ont donc là simplement
topalov le protège une fois de plus en
reculant pour la troisième fois la
cabanasse accueil
ça fait trois fois qu'il fait le
balancier toujours pour encadrer
maintenant ils défendent cavalli c6 et
il empêche toujours le con tre jeu à
base de d3 d4
ça fait un peu peur par impression
presse qui le nargue puisque e-menaces
fine du groupe in the navy
presque ananda à jouer des coups comme
cavalier scène par exemple pour attaquer
cavaler quatrième fois ce cavalier avec
le fond mais in fine et ça doit pas être
terrible terrible de jouer ça puisque
maintenant tu joues dame b2 simplement
donc là je prends des singes deuxième
c'est bien puisque la ont sommé
vis-à-vis du fou alors on n'a pas peur
ce type de manoeuvre 2,4 parce que le
cac prenant même le fouet la parcourt le
fou g2 est enfermé derrière son pion et
on resterait avec un client arriérés en
d3 puis on faible en d3 qui serait après
du coup sous le feu des pièces et demi
donc ça serait c'est une invitation à
faire une erreur et ce fut magnifique en
dessin qui fait il ya vis-à-vis du fou
j'ai donc on accélère un peu la suite
après foulée 4 1 en devient et le
taquiner maintenant sur les quatre mois
ils attaquent la tour il n'a pas trop le
choix maintenant on voit mal la torah
l'es16 puisqu'il y aurait fou à trois
avec
une en finale ici difficile apparaît
très pénible donc il faut prendre il
faut prendre je pense qu'ici maintenant
topalov n'a plus de problème en fait il
a résolu avec le fonds en d5 maintenant
il a complètement neutralisé le fou de
fous j'ai deux puis reprend la peur de
foule ou non la une très bonne structure
de pions on voit très bien qu'il a 2
donc il ya deux îlots contre 2 0 mais le
pion les 4 et est très faible puisqu'il
est tout seul alors vingt deux îlots au
premier rideau ici pour les assets b6 et
deuxième îlot ce paquet de pions et pour
pour les blancs c'est pareil à 2 0 il ya
deux et nommé un pion faible qui est
tout seul un pion un peu tout seul et
puis alors en finale ses deux pions
contreur ici donc il faut que l'inde
fasse attention à des transpositions au
final qui pourrait lui être défavorable
maintenant même si ses pions pour
l'instant s'il blanche doublé cinq ans
ils vont être dominés quelques en
quelque sorte à ce que les saints qui
sont à idron du mal quand et ça ça va
être chaud en fait c'est ça va soit être
donc une grande force parce qu'on va
pouvoir peut-être attaquer ensuite le
pion à 7
bien sûr l'intermédiaire de la colonne 1
du queens faiblesse faiblesse lorsque ça
sera donc un bien sûr case blanche donc
peut-être que les pièces noires vont
pouvoir l'attaquer wheel of sand casse
blanche bien sûr faut faire attention
en attendant la nonne a encore un atout
dans son château aussi puisqu'il a le
contrôle de la colonne c'est pas rien
c'est quand même très important aussi
donc alors tous ces six voilà les noirs
en fait voilà comprenant que la pression
des blancs j'ai quand même forte et puis
que la transposition au final plus il ya
des changes de pièces mais non plus il
deux pions contrôle on peut s'avérer
décisif
on dit souvent dans l'émission déception
éloigné plus c'était une finale de
roanne ce serait quasiment perdu donc il
faut faire très attention aux échanges
de pièces massif donc la proposent des
chances de pièces favorable au noir dans
ce type de position
donc là bessec alors ça l'idée plus
inquiet positionnelle donc on domine
avec b celle qu'on regarde et on empêche
à celle que vous y aurez la prise en
passant donc on domine peu ses deux
pions ce simple piaule domine de piau
donc ça permet de compenser ses deux
pions contre eux maintenant il faudra
que les blancs les noirs apprennent
d'abord ce tube est simple pour
prétendre un petit avantage elle dame
donc tout reprend ses deux tours france
et 2 ça c'est bon et ensuite simplement
là topalov vous ferez vous aussi c'est
surprenant parce que quand il est bien
aussi ci contre
car ayem me fous chez deux sétois en
fait ici en fait les replis c'est
important aussi de savoir dans cette
position quelle pièce les blancs
voudrait changer je pense qu'il serait
content d'échangés
le foot cases blanches les blancs dans
cette position jusque là vu que le pion
des cinq maintenant est faible donc on
semble garder vos maîtres prévu le
garder pour faire pression sur pyongyang
donc je pense que c'est très important
dans cette position justement donc
topalov s'est demandé quelle pièce il va
falloir que ces chants que les changes
et donc il s'est dit il faut absolument
garder sous deux cases blanches pour
réaliser une pression sur le pion v5 et
peut-être remplacé sur la case b5 par le
cavalier parce que ce cavalier peut-être
aussi pour revenir à ses sept plus tard
et d'action là dessus aussi donc ça peut
être une autre idée aussi alors et l'a
donc là alors on en profite pour réagir
alors très important ici maintenant coup
clip sans doute dans la position d'un
quart des 4 voilà des quatre
propositions de simplification au centre
et il aurait il a fallu pour un nombre
calculé deux coups puisque le coup la
partie ce4 d'auto pas là mais il ya
l'autre coup quand même deux pions prend
gagnon non parce qu'en fait les blancs
et puis jouer autour des 2 simplement
classique on ne reprend pas tout de
suite on fait un clouage ici le pion ne
peut pas dire d'un retour derrière et ce
pion et attaquer suffisamment pour
pouvoir être repris au coup suivant ce
un problème
donc ensuite on va reprendre avec le
cavalier en d4 qui va être ensuite
soutenu par le pion eux deux qui va
venir voler trois et lecavalier sera
vraiment très très fort en détective en
images est complètement la position
messieurs on y met alors si les noirs
j'avais joué un coup de com' cavaillès
cinq qui étaient possibles en recul même
envisagé fourrage trois fois
alors là coup de coude attendre par
exemple 2007 on prend faut pas être
simple tranquillement après prise
simplement en prend des cas du cavalier
mais après ce que tu nous expliques sait
qu'on va jouer le 3 et on accable énorme
parce qu'il est protégé par un pion
central et compte trois en plus la casse
et si ce qui est magnifique le koundan
cavaliers ou si quelqu un que le couple
le plus fort aux et chacun le couple
monstrueux
souvent le couple qui fait mal au roi
adverse un très très fort dans mes
cavaliers messieurs voilà tous étaient
donc évidemment alors tout par l'homme
ne rentre pas cette suite il jouait cas
pas là ils ferment donc en tout 1 4
ferme la position
il attaque le khalife 3 évidemment pose
la question aux cavaliers car les d2 et
là évidemment ça permet de prendre qui
ont des quatre alors qu'a prévu à dents
parce que là ça fait un pion tout de
suite mais non en fait parce qu'après
d'amendé 4 simplement alors les blanc
récuse d'abord même échangés ici sans
doute henri camous simplement cavaliers
prend 1,4 évidemment une foutaise
lecavalier
je pense aussi que c'est bon c'est
topalov dans ce match là il a loupé des
fois des petits moments critiques où il
avait peut-être la possibilité de
prendre des petits avantages et de
mettre plus de pression là je pense
qu'avec les noirs il a été là trop voulu
égaliser way est donc à oublier de
prendre un peu de risques alors que
c'est donc son style je pense qu'au lieu
de jouer dans le premier cas il aurait
pu il aurait pu tenter f500 rockets je
protégeais le pion aux quatre ans
protègent bien qu'à donc étouffe le fou
g2 et puis on à la casse des séries
qu'on peut jouer cavalier là que je fous
là on peut essayer après d'échangés
détours pourquoi pas on a toujours ses
deux pions contre un et on a peut-être
des thèmes de peut-être peut-être des
possibilités ensuite de jeu pour la
vente allant peut-être un peu trop
simplificateur là pour simplifier ici la
ville a la possibilité de jouer pour
pour l'activité
c'est compréhensible aussi bons d'un
côté c'est un match il a les noirs il se
dit bon demain j'aurai les blancs je
vais peut voir peut-être joyau n'a pas
davantage on a vu que hector et les
blancs c'est vrai que c'est rare avec
les normes donc ici car les points 4
mais hélas ils échangent donc là on voit
bien que topaloff est bien là ici
soulager la pression
donc maintenant on peut dire que la
position est quand même équilibré alors
problème quand même pour les blancs
c'est ceux qui ont des cinq ans un peu
tout seul on a quand même ici deux pions
qui peuvent être de plomb pas s'éloigner
très dangereux six options s'offrent
donc pour l'instant ils tiennent pas de
problème mais bon en contrepartie ceux
qui ont quand même aussi domine ses deux
pions pour l'instant ils sont immobiles
voilà donc mais le mail et blanc doivent
être passif parce qu'il faut
obtenir ce pion un pion de 5,6 à la clé
la pluie la position faut tenir le pion
b5 et puis il faut essayer peut-être
aussi de créer du contrôle sur le pion à
cette là pour l'instant on peut pas
jouer tout rade à cause du faux au cices
on ne peut pas jouer tour à 2 puisqu'il
n'ya le fulham et si on pouvait vivre
l'idéal ce serait de pouvoir jouer la
tendance s est joué peut-être tour ces
deux menaces et ours et 7 et peut-être
ensuite de jouer tour c'est un pur fait
retour à essayer de trouver des menaces
un peu comme ça pour attaquer le pion 17
mois en fait les noirs sont tout
simplement joué tour 17 contrôler la
septième rangée et protéger le pion à
cette contrôler la 7e ici sans problème
il n'y a pas de vrai problème pour les
noirs ici dont 3,7 et simplement les
blancs maintenant bay simplement mettre
leur pure alors ça c'est important que 3
ou simplement on met les pieds ont
regardé sur case noire avec un fou de
cases blanches donc les pions contre les
classes de la couleur opposée du fou que
donc ils sont complémentaires
la conception des scènes qui pose un
tout petit souci mais qui aussi qui est
aussi double champion et la femme faible
et puis à la fois il tient en respect
les pyrénées et les blancs aussi on est
un petit problème c'est qu'ils ont pas
de donc de cases pour le cavalier e 4
donc le cavalier leucate est bien placé
mais bon ils peuvent se faire chasser à
tout moment par l'action et la casse des
quatre voies l'asie sont pas ils sont là
et peut-être pour ça qu'il joue à trois
noms voilà j'ai joué trois pour
contrôler cette cage mais la foudre qui
joue qu'à valider eu carla bf3 calais
mais là c'est long c'est là une
manoeuvre
donc j'essaye donc la classique bon ben
on avait joué jusque là tricks près donc
ah on prend tranquille je prends et la
belladone de simplifier ou va-t-il voir
à long terme attention il peut être en
danger
un pion contre 2 c'est surtout ça le
thème et surtout est tombé 5 faible donc
il simplifie parce que s'il arrive à
éliminer les pions de son côté la bombe
est finalement
- y aura pions
plus ça sera nulle parce que même avec
une pièce de plus si si on sauve même
lâché une pièce à la limite pour les
buts les finales et finale deux tours
aussi sont très importantes il faut
qu'il faut absolument qu'ils jouent
dynamique dans ce type d'opposition faut
jouer dynamique donc f4 on échange on
fait des échanges donc s 4g prend f4f 4
et la tour des cadres l'activation de la
tour noire dans la tour nord commencent
à rentrer en jeu ici ont des quatre
peut-être que là tout revenir à 4 ans si
c'est possible et aussi on veut d'abord
jouer la tour dans le corner ce pour
jouer peut-être fou 17
parce que là on va commencer à faire
pression sur ce pion ici alors que si
dans mon avis les sectes loin des 8 tofu
17 soit juste pour des deux clous et le
fou c'est quand même embêtant
donc là simplement attendent alors très
important au final dans les dames sont
sortis donc les rois non plus trop peur
de maths et c'est des pièces qui pour
faire jouer les assurances ans il
travaillait à son endroit parce qu'on
fait jouer le roi qui devient une pièce
importante en finale
cabaye est celle de la part ici de
topalov donc là important alors un f 5
ou 6
si ce qu'avaient les bouches il pourra
venir l'un des six tours pareil avec le
kanak sur la place des cinq et on
empêche aussi le droit de venir en 3 et
donc d'assas et intra les mp3 bien sûr
hélas le temps qu'il fait froid alors
fait froid va on va pouvoir jouer
peut-être g4 et gf100 qu'il va quand
même enfermé un peu le roi n'en a aussi
parce que quand on a un pion comme ça on
n'empêche voilà on crée un petit couloir
et on va faire le roi noir alors si en
plus la tour peut venir faire un petit
échec
et puis on est embêté fixé le pion est
fier c'est très important justement
d'essayer de ne pas échanger fixer les
pions ne pas échanger ses pions donc les
deux pieds en contre l'avion et 6 mais
plutôt d'essayer de le fixer ensuite de
l'attaqué par avec le cavalier e cat et
la tour qui pourra se rendre en ashes
peinture contrôle bien
casey 4 ans ici donc fodé seck a
l'intention les noirs l'attaquent
regardez comme mon actif ces pièces très
bien du côté noir is it assurent le
cavalier ou 4 est en prise donc il faut
faire quelque chose simplement cabinets
des deux est par contre ça permet
l'échangé de foot les changes de fous se
fabrique ici il tacle et on reprend du
cavalier la tour est attaqué et là on va
voir comment cette finale retour
cavaillé contre tours carrées on peut
dire que là maintenant suite à ces
échanges bon de topalov a clairement
bombe
l'initiative on peut dire quand même un
petit peu mieux et ça tourne quand même
beaucoup plus active que celle là qui
est défensive mais on a d'autres qui ont
contraint ici et deux pions contrôle de
l'autre côté on peut dire déjà que c'est
quasi nul c'est une position également
l'action position donc on va avoir un
peu la suite pour voir comment les
grands maîtres joue ce type de position
quand même donc ici tour à 4 et la bombe
le plan annoncé g4 alors c'est quand
même dangereux parce que j'ai 4
attention il faut bouger le cavalier
puis après ben bella tour attaque deux
pions ici donc mais évidemment il a
prévu qu'ils pouvaient venir protéger
avec le roi a pris cavaliers des six ici
simplement calais des six voilà
simplement encouragé 3 on protège bien
les deux pions de roi le roi noir aussi
est un petit peu un petit peu il faut
faire attention quand même au nahd de
pions il ya le cavalier qui est pas très
loin le cavalier voire à des thèmes
aussi c'est que ici bien sûr une
adoption éloigné contre eux mais là ça
c'est des pions qui sont proches et non
pas éloigné et proche de quoi proche du
moins donc évidemment on voit quand même
comme qui ont f5 le roi commence à être
un peu emprisonnés
l'opinion contre wall e les 15 de
fuyants f6 commence à être faible le
plus réussi c'est fait et puis si on est
sur la 7ème là le roi il est obligé
d'aller sur l'amitié elle va peut-être
avoir des thèmes de matty voilà sur
l'amitié ont dit par les cavaliers
cheikh donc la pelote réagi par câble et
l'échec qui ciblent centre moi je monte
un petit peu et il veut aussi l'arrivée
a joué 5 s'il arrivait à faire un petit
échec poussé le roi derrière alors
bienvenue en justice il faut jouer très
actif et scié je pense qu'il a il a deux
coups de prendre le pion v5
il ya cavaliers des six tours à 5 il le
fait au pâlot fils a pas alors faut pas
leur premier cas des menaces là mais il
va créer une contrebasse sur le pont b5
et on va voir alors là c'est magnifique
la suite puisque un homme ne va pas à
tenter de s'accrocher espions vêtements
justement un peu idiot alors qu'il a une
belle initiative de ce côté on va voir
que ça va compenser la perte de ce pion
c'est toute la magie de cette fin de
partie que même en effet partie qui
aurait comme ça c'est pas simple jeu
matérialiste qui permet une hauteur et
positions souvent il s'avère dynamique
est donc ici simplement autour des 2
donc proposé vas-y bob le pion aux
poissons n'y a pas trop le choix sinon
on jouerait sa mort on s'éloigne un
petit peu des opérations on va jouer une
scène sans doute après on va peut-être
cavaliers des quatre cavaliers c6
échelle aussi jouer qu'avec des quatre
caves les c6 bien sûr ça peut être très
pénible or il faut prendre le pion entre
certaines entreprises c'est ce qui fait
et lifesize award et c'est malin il fait
pas échec n'aura pu faire échec mais
dans ce cas-là ce riche avec le roi
serait venu sans doute ans le 6 on joue
d'abord ipsec et la menace échec et le
roi dont elles sont les huitièmes il est
pris au piège aussi il est dans une
espèce de bois qu'il ne veut un petit
couloir très pénible
regardez aussi comme le projet car ici
empêche la tour eu le temps de faire
échec ce qui permet aux bleus laurent
blanc de passer et s'ils arrivent à
pénétrer en v6 de créer des réseaux de
maths c'est quasi des réseaux de maths
qui peuvent aller très très vite donc
c'est
ça fait chaud aux fesses quand même à
balles à la sortie prend un autre
tournant pensé que c'était égal que ça
allait se terminer en deux trois coups
mais non un mandat finalement donné ce
pion de 5 et commence à créer des
menaces contre le droit de leur côté ci
du blanc n'arrivent pas à concrétiser
leur menace pour créer des choses
dangereuses il ya deux pions passive
alors très vite
pauvre pauvre trouve ça va à dame est
assez noir qu'il est rentable donc il
faut que le dynamisme au moins à défaut
de gagner la partie permettent de
contrer la menace de ses crimes passés
on va voir ce que c'est ce qui va se
passer tours cadeaux topalov l'idée
simple c'est de pouvoir venir recettes
dont cas d'échec simplement et
simplement on devait lui avant son roi
tranquille sans qu on voit bien aussi
que toutes les pièces blanches sont
coordonnées donc la tour d2 qui va
menacer de rentrer sur la 7e le cavalier
qui est pas très loin donc après après
par exemple un g4 g5 qui pourrait
devenir très actif de ces cases noires
faire un échec
le roi en h5 donc et alors que le
cavalier noir en bessin qui a l'air un
petit peu hors jeu il peut pas venir en
d6 il est un peu bloqué ici en restant
ne peux pas trop bouger en eux mêmes en
d4 il est bloqué parce qu'elle cavalier
blanc il n'a pas de casutt il n'a pas de
casier effectivement donc là d'un tout
autre ordre déstabiliser petit peu ce
cas ce cavalier le f3 qui vient
simplement il n'y a pas le choix parce
que si lecavalier était venu il n'y a
pas d'autres cases la partie 1 jérémy
occase très très très facile l'art est
très facile donc ici calais h41 de kazim
seul coup un peu actif alors là bien là
ils en profitent maintenant il va
essayer de ramener bc cavaliers en
défense que des trains
bien ce biais là quand il le joue en c3
sans camani parole libère aussi ses
pions lorient lui aussi peut-être essayé
à saint cloud à quatre c'est peut-être
possible ancien poste militaire à cinq
essais se dépêcher non parce que plus
vite ce pion noir va arriver là plus
vite les blancs devant sont occupés non
ici il faut faire attention peut-être un
coup comme peut-être tourbe et deux
attaquants le calme cavaliers b 5 tours
b 2 et si le cas est les bouches c b6
qui saute et tout de suite il est moins
dangereux ceux qui ont le pouvoir le
contrôler par l'arrière et ça va être
difficile
donc là après cavale et ses trois tours
17 voilà c'est l'heure de jouer autour
des 7 et la tour 7 comme prévu mais
alors évident on n'échange pas parce que
si les blancs échanges maintenant vallée
d'orle avantage parce que là il ya un
pion passé fort ici en plus sur la
colonne à qui est très difficile à
arrêter pour le cavalier qui ont passé
extérieur en général en finale c'est
pratiquement un point surtout avec les
cavaliers et a eu un échange de quoi les
blancs non seulement ils ont du mal à
avancer il faudrait il changer le pion
mais en plus le roi a déjà placé pour
arrêter et le cavalier noir va très vite
devenir aussi et c'est qu'ils ont passés
lions faire la différence donc ça serait
une erreur gravissime d'échangés qui il
ne faut pas échanger l'idée c'était de
d'enlever la tour noire de sa position
active pour replacer sa tour en d3 et
gagner du temps ici sur les cavaliers
fulcrum les bouge donc la calle au
théâtre un pur pour topalov simplement
up pénétration une voix saïss cavalli
s'activent attaque la tour cette
attention c'est tout contrôler à la fois
la septième bombe et attaques aussi le
cavalier fait un protège son cavalier
peut-être y avoir maintenant il commence
à y avoir des petits réseaux du matin si
on voit très bien que dans cette
position si les blancs avec va mettre le
roi en a six
alors si on est le roi alors par exemple
imaginons que les droits si bon belge ou
la tour par exemple c'est cette voie là
donc si on arrive à mettre l'euro à 1 h
6000 euros 1 h 6 il ne souffrirait que
d'une tournée de fuite pour faire un
chacun il est par exemple sur bessèges
tour des huit et loire et le rhône
il n'a pas de gaz on n'attend pas
l'instant il n'est pas un échec mais la
menace blanche après belayat patrouille
l'imaginant à n'importe quel coût il n'y
a pas en fait on a passé matin par able
nos références même tour 17,1 me prends
pas même pas la tour ont simplement tu
aurais fini mat
regardez comme c'est magnifique c'est un
match très connue alors les lecavalier
protège la tour empêche recettes le pion
empêche le roi de bouger le tuyau noir
bloc a raillé comme un lob de faveur et
audemat dont on parle depuis tout à
l'heure
donc là tout est attaqué de cavale et c5
de topalov donc évidemment qui met
contre attaque en fait tout simplement
sur la tour contre attaque selon m hélas
y arriver c'est très très mal parce que
si les noirs joué tour vu tout de suite
ici il joue et on a mis ton pourrait
jouer et aux riches et chacun va bouge
et on peut même jeu rouages 6 avec
menaces de matonge à sa plate forme à
gimont i chèques pour acheter forcée
voilà et au racisme ne peut pas empêcher
matin encore un match regardez c'est fou
parce que le cavalier blanc protège la
case f8 et h 8
donc on peut pas jouer ça mais par
contre 1 en jouant d'abord c'est malin
ils sont malins ces joueurs alors qu'en
afrique elle est alors rejoint d'abord
cave est nécessaire
il m'écoute sais pas si tu prends je
prends et c'est la même idée j'ai deux
pions pas ces lignes je gagne et en plus
en jouant ça donc il faut que tu bouges
et si tu bouges je peux jouer après tour
puisqu'il ya plutôt des 7 je contrôle
aussi lacazette
c'est presque un premier recul je pense
que bon il avait quand même des miracles
à calculer
t'auras 3 donc ici tourner cette
tranquille si toro 3 il revient il
essaie de le travailler au corps alors
ça ça empêche la tour on peut de bouger
puisqu'il y aura trouvé cet échec
donc moi j'ai sept des coudes attentes
en fait difficilement peu diffusion a
passé et là où se décide à essayer de
passer par g5
l'ag s'est créé puis voilà s'il est
décidé de noir prennent en transit au
moins on pourra menacer m6 et sheila
leroy avoir des vrais soucis ouest
roland donc là les seniors pour les
noirs de eux-mêmes contre-attaqué par b5
voilà il faut absolument que les noirs
crédit contre jeu et menace d'aller donc
un prêt puis on prend m6 serait roi
prend une finale donc on joue pas
compris ce qu'on va prendre attaque le
pion et ça serait pas bon il faut
laisser le roi sur sa case g7 donc
carrière 4,4 là peut menacer des coups
comme cavalier chien qui s'y rouge et
jécistes échec avec des menaces d'aller
chercher le matin tout simplement
donc il faut que les noirs continuent
leur plein de diversion classique quand
vous avions passé on est dans le flou le
pousser sacré diversion il faut
absolument créer des diversions ici et
là regardez comme un an de vous ne se
pressent pas toujours pareil on prend
pas ça libérerait au droit alors voilà
ratage des blancs c'est d'avoir le roi
adverse en cage
j'ai six chalets de combat très puissant
on va le voir par la suite parce que là
ça crée on a un réseau beaucoup de
précision contrôle s'est casé plus que
des cases de huitième pour le roi noir
ça fait plein fouet leur attention matin
alors donc b3 tension aussi on avoir
dévoilé double menace
attention la l'option passé qui bouge
regarder comment ça finit avec tour ces
trois maintenant commencer à attaquer
ici attention si ce cavalier seul
cavalier cheikh walid
imaginons parler
ajoutez deux ici tout prend bnda super g
faits d'armes oui mais en fait cavalier
this échec et tour ses huit échecs et
mat
après les tours vite mais voilà donc
voyez c'est très vite matin et donc faut
faire gaffe à tour ces trois menaces
d'un truc de match donc il faut faire
gaffe c'est pour ça s'explique le coup
suivant topalov qu'il faut jouer
maintenant qu'elles ont des quatre qui
n'est qu'à lui si ce n'est pas possible
le cavalier protège encore en voilà et
après tout reprend ses seins tombants f4
échec au g8 est en fait grâce à ce pion
ici qui menacent de faire dame les
blancs sont obligés de jeter un oeil
dessus trouvé cela ils ont même pas le
temps de faire tout reprend 1,7 parce
que surtout reprend à cette horde et ce
sont les noirs qui se met derrière leurs
pions sacem vous qu'elle connaît à
connaître en finale quand même c'est
très fort à cela on peut plus venir
chercher donc il va falloir redescendre
sinon c b 2 et après on peut plus
empêcher d'aller là on a encore la
possibilité de faire des petits échecs
tourabi littoral sont on doit encore
faire des écharpes et url
voilà c'est la scène on est obligé de
prendre le patch un peu ce qui se passe
dans la partie puisque après tomber
cette simplement tour f3 et là la menace
des noirs 27 jouer la scène qu un 4 à 3
et c'est fini c'est de plomb fondane
donc pour ça que les blancs jouent
simplement échec 3 g 7 nuls parce que
simplement l'échec échec échec
évidemment il fallait pas tomber dans le
petit piège de jouer roi h61 oui quoi je
suis là on pourrait se dire mais je
jouais ashes comme ça je menace malte
mais ces lois qui se formater ascension
après après après six heures de jeu
c'est dur ça arrive ça arrive ça t'est
arrivé ça ça m'est déjà donc il faut
faire gaffe en vouloir trop gagner
souvent on perd donc il faut quand même
faire grève donc là c'est les blancs
prennent échec pour bitumer voyez comme
cette finale est très instructif puisque
à la fois la menace de maths des blancs
du côté droit et la contrebasse de
pousser les pions du côté des noirs donc
ça reste dynamique malgré mon absence
d'égalité matériel il y avait comme une
dissymétrie de pions de contrôle d'un
côté de contrôle l'autre il fallait
faire jouer cette dissymétrie des deux
côtés leroy aussi on a vu très bien le
donc le roi blanquette engins donc il
faudrait il faut activer son voit dans
croix géante d'ailleurs wife 2,3 g iii
roi jusqu'à 3,5 il faut vraiment active
et son roi le parcours du roi qui parti
qui est parti d'ici qu'est venue la tue
presque la récuse ce qui arriva en htc
on allait ce qui a sauvé les blancs
finalement dans cette finale c'est la
coordination des pièces on a vu que le
roi la tour et le cavalier jouer
ensemble avec les pions et donc ils ont
réussi à créer des menaces de match qui
fait ce qui fait que les noirs n'ont
jamais pu finalement faire dame avec ses
deux pions allen dame donc ils font une
faute toujours précis il
c'est jamais c'est jamais fini une
partie d'échecs voyez le dynamisme en
tout cas est toujours souvent la clé de
sortie mais merci karima 2 rien merci
merci beaucoup merci à toi on se
retrouve dans la deuxième j'espère bien
parti on espère que ça va être chaud je
pense que ça va être très chaud la
dernière la dernière 1 6 3 la fin avec
les blancs qui va prendre des risques
pour essayer de gagner pour essayer
d'éviter les leucémies rapide face à un
an d'un car tout le monde connaît la
réputation de benhadj comme comme au
foot outil c'est un lien administratif
il disait que quand comme quand il était
jeune tigana il n'aimait pas c'est
pareil aux échecs qui a dit fort qu'il
n'est pas une interrogation merci nous
l'avons suivi pour cette magnifique 11e
partie championne mandoune en rendez
vous pour la dernière partie longue
en tout cas au moins de ce championnat
la 12e dans la prochaine émission
diagonale tv pourquoi